well good morning ladies and gentlemen
it's been a fascinating morning don't
you think do prizewinners live longer
and why scientifically might we care
whether or not they do this is joint
work with a young British researcher
called Matthew Raylan and a key stimulus
for our paper was an article published a
little bit over a decade ago in the
annals of internal medicine in 2001 by
Redell Meyer and Singh those authors
made the fascinating but provocative
claim that winning an Oscar would if you
can manage it ladies and gentlemen would
increase the length of your life by just
under four years in a causal sense
remarkably compared merely to being
nominated so what about the effect of
other kinds of awards I must say when we
began this work I was skeptical that we
would find any effect from winning
either even a major award and I I
worried about some of the statistical
structures in the rebel Myron Singh
paper but we'll come back to that
Matthew and I collected data anyway went
ahead on half a century of Nobel Prize
winners in chemistry and physics these
individuals were born on average in
around 1870 that gave us a usable sample
of about 135
yes wandering at 135 winners and a
little bit under 400 nominees well when
I say a nominee here I'll mean someone
who was nominated but did not win this
is not a large sample by my kind of
world but it's a start
if you look at the raw data this is what
you find and it's true these are these
are remarkably long-lived individuals
considering they were born in the year
1870 you think about it it's true that
winners live a year or two longer than
normal ease but these are just averages
we can't read any kind of causality from
these numbers and rebel Myron's thing
wouldn't have said that either the
literature that's pursued this line has
done
various kinds of Corrections to try to
get closer to cause and effect the
notion here is that we can think about
status as being randomly assigned at the
margin among a group of people otherwise
very similar in characteristics and one
underlying theory is that if you have
status or perhaps happiness showered
upon you in an outside way what a
researcher might call an exogenous way
perhaps in some mysterious fashion that
would be protective for your physical
system for your health so we constructed
a matching test pairing each winner with
a nominee closest in characteristics I
cannot tell you the methods today and
also a regression equation test looking
at the same kind of issue setting at a
somewhat higher statistical bar than and
perhaps rebel Myron Singh say it
intuitively what we're doing here is
we're comparing the longevity of winners
against nominees conditional on the
nominee being alive of course at the
time the winner won that's the only way
to get the appropriate test our results
against my early guesses continue to
find evidence statistically significant
evidence consistent with the notion that
winning the prize would raise your life
span not by three point six years only a
year or two but this is how the data
came out and of course we reported these
results a little while ago in a
published paper this ties into a broader
literature which some in the room may
know about we're gathering evidence that
there are profound links between how
your mind works perhaps one might say
your mental well-being and how your your
body functions how healthy your system
is if you read journals called psycho
neuro endocrinology then you'll run into
the work of people like Weinman at
London doing very interesting work
taking bits of flesh out of people like
you I don't know what they have to pay
their volunteers the wounds inflicted in
that way are then the rate of heal
is then measured compared to adults of
the same kind and this is how the
technical jargon comes out but in
everyday English Winelands team shows
there's a literature showing that
happier people heal up faster if they
have standardized size puncture wounds
there's a concept standardized size
puncture wounds some of you will know
the Coen studies from Carnegie Mellon
which are also in the same vein there's
also some evidence that happiness if you
can manage it ladies and gentlemen will
make you live longer there is some
evidence one of the early studies was a
study of a group of nuns some of them
are still living nu ns and this is now
famous in the Applied Psychology
literature and part of bet the
behavioral science literature because
these nuns recorded their early emotions
in their teens they their Diaries have
been kept and it has transpired against
I think what I would have predicted and
perhaps what you would have predicted
that the emotional words in the Diaries
when these youngsters were in their
teens has turned out to be remarkably
predictive of how long each individual
lives this has the advantage compared to
studying oscar-winners that I'm afraid a
very large proportion of these nuns like
chemists and physicists from my era have
died which is very useful if you're
studying lifespan formally we find this
kind of negative correlation to sum up
ladies and gentlemen now it is true that
Nobel Prize winners do live longer now
whenever you say such a thing you have
to decide longer against whom but
interestingly to me and perhaps to you
they live longer than nominees even when
we do the most formal statistical
Corrections that so far the literature
has been able to do it is very widely
thought I'm sure you've heard it said
you may have said it that a healthy body
leads to a healthy mind part of my
life's work is on looking at the
structure of happiness equations or
mental well-being equations and exercise
hours and fruit and
consumption so oncoming strongly along
with many other things of course in
those happiness equations it may be this
literature suggests that there's a kind
of reverse causality there's a two-way
flow and happiness and Status may
themselves be protective of the body we
certainly don't understand why or how
but it may be they may be protective of
the body let me stress the word may in
that sentence because like the benefits
of the French Revolution it's just a
little bit too early to say
thank you very much
Hey